c'est la fin
[Musique]
g
lorsque j'ai créé ma chaîne youtube
c'était fin 2016 décembre 2016 je me
suis dit je sais pas sur quoi je parle
c'est ma commence pas mais je sais que
j'y vais j'avais très envie de créer des
vidéos je vais faire des vidéos tous les
jours puisque une tous les jours c'est
la boucherie
[Musique]
et puis ça a commencé comme ça alors des
premiers débuts un petit peu hasardeuse
pas toujours hyper évident et puis
ensuite le temps de trouver sa voie
d'annoncé travailler travailler
travailler puis se dire début 2017
j'y vais à fond une vidéo par jour et
ces partis monde connecté atari iphone 8
au nord huit pros ipad pro
[Musique]
alors au début ce n'était pas dans le
studio et puis après c'est arrivé ici à
peu près je dirais en deux ans et demi
du début jusqu'à maintenant
il s'est passé beaucoup de choses une
communauté grandissante et je vous en
remercie énormément vous êtes
aujourd'hui plus de 200000 présent sur
la chaîne et de le dire des fois j'ai du
mal à y croire
cinquante mille abonnés 99999 modérée la
ferai ma porte a rencontré une marche
entre nous la mairie hier à 90,9 1999
tu touches patrick sanville
[Musique]
on a perdu 1 200 milles 44 ans qui s'est
passé beaucoup de choses
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
mais les choses changent les choses
évoluent et un moment il faut passer à
autre chose si on veut réussir en tout
cas évoluer et aller dans le bon sens le
studio ici alors je vous ai pas tout dit
ça fait bizarre parce que tout le matos
que vous avez là c'est immatériel que
j'ai accumulée depuis depuis des années
depuis tant que je travaille que les
années ça fait peut-être un an et demi
deux ans a donc il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de matos accumulé
beaucoup de bateaux ce que j'ai
effectivement et la voyez ça fait quand
même pas mal de choses avec du matos
également de ce côté-là nas pour pouvoir
faire tout le mond stockage ma veste du
que tu vois il ya pas mal pas mal de
matos mon smartphone ya aussi le
pétrolier de la mode connecté va ya
tellement de choses que voilà ça on
vient sa dégaine un peu tous les côtés
mais tout ça tout ce matériel a une
histoire et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
chargé d'émotion qu'aujourd'hui je
prends tout ça je remballe fois je me
trouve des cartons il pleut un peu là
mais pas énormément donc croyez moi ça
ça fait quand même quelque chose c'est
la fin c'est la fin quelque chose ici
c'est la fin de quelque chose ici c'est
le commencement ailleurs c'est une
continuité c'est un parcours
mais même si un côté un petit peu n'a
comme on va dire un peu pas nostalgique
pas tristesse ça fait quelque chose on
va aller tout ça c'est une page qui sont
très clairement c'est une étape c'est
quelque chose de très personnel parce
que vous savez même si vous êtes de plus
en plus nombreux et nombreuses
je suis très heureux de pouvoir vous
rencontrer partager avec vous échangez
quand on se croise mais malgré tout ça à
sam etiassé solitaire face à une caméra
et tout ça c'est les choses qu'eux
j'ai monté par l'antenne des
partenariats des échanges avec des
marques désauté plein de trucs beaucoup
de travail beaucoup d'investissements
deux ans de ma vie à quelque chose près
et le fait de les prendre et déménagé
quelques pas dans ce nouveau projet qui
veut devenir encore plus grand
sainte-thérèse chose c'est pas rien
[Musique]